bonsoir édition spéciale du 7-8
politique en ce lundi 14 décembre nous
allons revenir sur les élections du
second tour des élections régionales
pour l'île de france alors que vous
allez voir apparaître les résultats
justement pour notre région et cette
victoire de valérie pécresse 43,80 % des
suffrages exprimés la liste républicain
udi modem qui remporte 121 sièges sur
les 209 possible la gauche qui perd
cette région qu'elle détenait depuis 17
ans et puis voyez aussi ses chiffres ce
sont les résultats pour les yvelines
34,41 % seulement pour le parti
socialiste europe écologie et le front
de gauche en 2010 aux précédents
scrutins la même alliance totalisé 49,45
% pour commenter ces différents
résultats là trois invités en plateau
alexandra dublanche bonsoir pour les
républicains adjointe à la politique de
la ville au transport à sartrouville
vous êtes candidate élue à la région
donc ce soir gaël kalouki bonsoir
bienvenue en plateau candidate ps dans
les yvelines et françois simeoni bonsoir
vaut aussi un candidat pour le front
national sur cette liste yvelines le
front national qui aura des élus jugent
dans cette nouvelle assemblée ce n'était
pas le cas en 2010 cette fois ci la
formation de marine le pen aura 22 et
sièges pour les républicains
quelle analyse vous faites de ce
résultat pour commencer mais écoutez
tout d'abord merci pour cette invitation
c'est une victoire amplement méritée
c'est le fruit d'un travail depuis des
années des années de valérie pécresse et
de ses colistiers de ses militants sur
le terrain dans toutes les
circonscriptions d'île de france et plus
de 150 déplacement dans sa
circonscription à nouveau et à nouveau
donc le travail vraiment qui est qui a
fini par payer un petit à hantay sur
sartrouville puisque je suis lutz a
retrouvé c'est la première fois que la
droite arrive en tête à des élections
nationales depuis années 90 donc là
aussi c'est une grande victoire
après c'est aussi une très grande
responsabilité ce n'est pas un chèque en
blanc les franciliens nous ont fait il
ya beaucoup de travail sur la table il
faut rattraper tout ce qui n'a pas été
fait depuis 17 ans par la majorité à
l'ancienne majorité socialiste il ya des
dossiers très importants dans les
yvelines sur lequel il faut qu'on avance
rapidement je pensais à tangentielle
nord je pense à eole la rénovation de
certains lycées donc voilà c'est une
grande responsabilité beaucoup de
travail peut être juste un mot sur cette
déclaration de benoît hamon c'était ce
matin sur l'antenne de france info
valérie pécresse a été élu sur son
programme par des électeurs du front
national
écoutez moi je sais encore la ccl une
image de cette campagne c'était toujours
des petites phrases de la part de
l'équipe opposée il n'y a pas eu de
travail de fond nous voilà on nous
propose des solutions pour les français
n'y a pas de là valérie pécresse est la
candidate de tous les franciliens la
présidente de tous les franciliens ya
pas de on a été élu sur ces électeurs là
plutôt que d'autres on ne pose pas elle
a rassemblé elle a su rassembler dès le
début et c'est ce qui a fait sa victoire
françois simioni je vous fait réagir
vous passerez la parole juste après mais
puisqu'on parlait du front national et
de ses électeurs on verra tout à l'heure
le détail des chiffres mais une partie
de vos électeurs ne vous ont pas à
solliciter une deuxième fois lors du
second tour non c'est pas tout à fait ça
en fait moi je n'arrive pas dans
l'entretien je tiens à les remercier des
à ses électeurs
ils étaient très nombreux à voir porter
suffrages sur le front national au
premier tour et au deuxième tour en ile
de france
effectivement une partie nos électeurs
qui ont fait un choix qui ont fait le
choix de sortir la gauche
voilà ça c'était cet effectif maintenant
ce choix amène quand même si on regarde
les chiffres au niveau des voix 1
il faut relativiser parce que au premier
tour sur l'île de france et plus
particulièrement sur les yvelines on a
en est en progression encore ont été en
progression par rapport aux
départementales on a gagné 1200 voix par
rapport aux départementales et le recul
que vous mentionnez aider au choix de
nos électeurs d'effectivement de sortir
la liste de gauche doit être aussi
relativiser parce que ses deux amis le
voient en moi l'ensemble de l'île de ces
masses elles 85 à 73 me voir onze mille
voix je crois bon peu importe mais
effectivement vous avez vous avez si on
compare ce nombre de voix par rapport
aux voix des européennes bien ça ne fait
que 1500 voix de mon
je me rappelle que pour les européennes
on avait dit que le front national avait
remporté un franc succès vous voyez qui
a finalement une évolution peu
importante et puis encore une fois je
précise que c'est un choix des électeurs
du front national dames 2e tour savait
très bien qu'on va vous savez votre gîte
il s'était abattu ses cartes voulons
prier de la gauche voilà bon maintenant
je pense que ces électeurs reviendront à
nous sans aucune sans aucune difficulté
et au point de vue national vous avez vu
ce qui s'est passé on peut pas parler de
l'échec au front national on augmente en
nombre de voix on est à 6,6 millions de
de français qui votent pour nous en
progression encore par rapport aux
élections précédentes on est à 30 % des
français à faudra leur expliquer comment
avec ces résultats là où on décroche pas
de région car c'est vrai que les
sondages nous donnaient gagnant dans les
régions n'étaient que des sondages
maintenant expliquant aux français
pourquoi avec ces résultats là on a que
sont alertés oui d'accord mais
effectivement exprimé exact mais le mode
de scrutin c'est qu'on remporte 0 région
ce qui est complètement anormal
le mode de scrutin c'est que on a que
deux députés ce qui est anormal qu'on a
que deux sénateurs ce qui est anormal
donc voilà je pense que les français
vont réfléchir à tout ça et notamment
aussi les électeurs de droite ils vont
faire la part des choses certains disent
ils critiquent les résultats de paca et
d'une heure en dix ans on a été élu
d'accord mais on a été élu avec les voix
de la gauche
on va rester sur les résultats de
l'hiver france je reviendrai vers vous
juste après pour le parti socialiste à
présent à l'issue du premier tour claude
bartolone qui affichait la gauche c'est
le premier parti c'est la première
formation en ile-de-france forcément
hier c'était un petit peu plus compliqué
hier soir oui alors je pense qu'il faut
rappeler qu on n'était pas forcément
parti favori dans ce scrutin et je crois
que la gauche c'est un résultat plutôt
honorable même si c'est évidemment une
une déception de perdre cette région
surtout quand on voit le bilan le bilan
de jean paul huchon et du bilan de
l'ensemble des études gauche sur la
région ile de france
cependant je crois qu'on a réussi à
rassembler la gauche au second tour sans
voix
très nettement avec une une
participation importante une hausse de
participation aussi au second tour
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
je crois que c'est significatif et que
ça doit nous amener à continuer à aller
vers vers ces quartiers a continué à
parler à ses quartiers à faire de la
politique aussi pour ces gens qui ont
besoin de la gauche au niveau de l'île
de france après je voulais revenir sur
ce que vous disiez sur le effectivement
le fait que valérie pécresse a été élu
en grande partie avec les voix du front
national
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est benoît
hamon c'est la question posée je posais
des questions proposées en introduction
et je pense que ça il faut l'analyser
sereinement
c'est à dire que ça n'est pas le fruit
du hasard c'est une construction ça a
été construit par valérie pécresse par
son équipe avec une campagne qui a été
ancrée très à droite je pense notamment
sous le travail de fond qui avait été
fait avec un certain nombre de groupes
de droite assez radicale avec la manif
pour tous aussi enfin voilà avec un
certain nombre de groupes de droite donc
une vraie stratégie pour aller chercher
des voix du front national stratégique
et par ailleurs assumer un certain
nombre de militants d'élus ump du
département et notre territoire
et puis qui se voit aussi dans les actes
très concrètement quand on a assez
récemment des élus ump et des adjoints
au maire sur saint quentin en yvelines
ou sur département plus largement qui
reprennent publiquement des propos du
front national qui relaie sur les
réseaux sociaux
là encore des propos de groupuscules
d'extrême droite sur des attaques à des
colistiers de claude bartolone ou encore
récemment un élu un élu du département
qui
qui m'expliquait que des migrants n'est
milliers de femmes et d'enfants qui
meurent en méditerranée ça n'est que le
résultat d'une sélection naturelle donc
on a quand même une radicalisation une
porosité extrêmement forte entre le
front national et l'ump qui n'est pas le
fruit du hasard qui n'est pas
juste de la petite phrase mais qui est
vraiment une construction qui doit nous
interroger
parce que je pense que ça pose un vrai
problème en termes démocratique vous
souhaitez réagir
oui tout à fait voilà encore une fois
c'est tout à fait révélateur de cette
campagne stigmatisation de certains
électeurs les uns contre les autres on
les oppose
valérie pécresse ce qu'elle a voulu dans
cette campagne c'est répondre aux
besoins et aux attentes des citoyens
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils veulent de
la sécurité après les terribles
événements que nous avons vécue
récemment ils veulent de l'emploi et
donc c'est quelque chose qu'elle a
adressée contrairement à claude
bartolone qui dans sa profession de foi
ne prononce même pas une fois le mot
sécurité enfin c'est complètement
hallucinant dans la période que nous
connaissons actuellement
donc non il n'y a pas de stratégie pour
aller prendre des voix je ne sais où il
ya une réponse aux besoins et aux
attentes des franciliens et les
électeurs l'ont entendu et l'ont reconnu
et l'ont plébiscité juste très
rapidement je pense qu'il ya une
différence entre répondre à des attentes
les problématiques posées par nos
concitoyens posées par des électeurs et
courir après les thèses du front
national
et je pense que c'est là où on a un vrai
risque en termes démocratique c'est
quand à droite dite républicaine qui
traditionnellement s'est toujours opposé
au front national quand cette droite là
se met à courir après les thèses du
front national à reprendre les thèmes du
front national et les propositions du
front national aussi
je pense que là il ya un vrai risque il
ya une vraie inquiétude est que c'est de
la responsabilité des élus de se poser
ces questions-là enfin si manning bien
sûr qu'on innombrables a voulu bien sûr
on parle beaucoup de nous comment
recevoir la menace fasciste là donc je
tiens quand même à préciser que les
propos haineux ils ont été largement
partagée et notamment par la gauche
puisque je fais allusion à la campagne
de manuel valls qui applaudit campagne
parce qu'effectivement c'est le
directeur de campagne puisqu'il a
utilisé tout simplement que voter pour
le front national s'était amené la
guerre civile je prends la circulaire
envoyée par claude bartelone aux
électeurs où il était dit que en ile de
france on a évité la morsure du front
national dont je pense que je me blesse
doit mordre sûrement comme tous les gens
du front national jeu
je des propos très très graves ont été
ont été tenus sur un sur un site sur le
site de l'ops une tribune où on appelait
aucun appeler un docteur je crois appelé
au viol des électrices du front national
j'ai peu vu aucune relation aucune
réaction
voilà deux vis-à-vis de cette de ces
faits inqualifiables
alors moi je pense que la guerre civile
elle est en france le 13 novembre c'est
des français qui ont tué des français
donc le résultat de ces politiques très
mauvaise d'immigration d'insécurité et
de communautarisme nous ont amené à
cette guerre civile alors c'est pas ici
au front national qu'on doit faire c'est
reproche c'est au système ump est ce
qu'il a construit sa va réagir chacun
sur cette question va juste avant c'est
un petit peu parce que j'aimerais tout
même à vous entendre aussi sur la
question de l'abstention
l'abstention qui est moins forte sur ce
deuxième tour que la semaine dernière 41
59 % dans l'intégralité de la france
contre 45,2 54% pour l'île de france est
un petit peu moins bien et
spécifiquement dans les yvelines à 43 %
des inscrits ne se sont toujours pas à
déplacer françois simeoni je vais rester
avec vous tout simplement parce que à
mantes-la-ville c'est une commune que le
front national dirige donc département
c'est plus de 53 % d'abstention et le fn
termine d'ailleurs troisième derrière la
gauche et la droite
écoutez au 1er tour vous avez vu ce qui
s'est passé le front national a été un
plébiscite pour le front national vous
avez dans les mairies tenu par le front
national
des scores qui sont allés jusqu'à 60% et
là sur le second tour se densifie non
mais le problème ce sont des
problématiques du second tour je voulais
expliquer les gens au second tour on
souhaitait une partie de notre électorat
souhaitait sortir la gauche c'est
différent c'est pas la même
problématique may 1 53 % d'abstention
dans cette commune là si on parle de
cette rumeur oui mais si vous voulez les
chiffres de l'abstention sont ce qu'ils
sont effectivement mais le problème
c'est de motiver les électeurs et la
motivation pour ce pour ce second tour
je vous lis avec cette complexité dans
les appels au vote
comment comment voulez vous qu'on s'y
retrouve les gens du dans certaines
régions les gens de gauche appelés à
voter à droite les gens droite appelé à
voter à gauche français
on ne peut pas s'y retrouver donc je
pense que c'est le problème de
l'abstention c'est un problème qui
existe mais ce qui est c'est pop
évidemment un problème qui concerne le
front national encore une fois c'est je
vous rappelle les chiffres en termes de
nombre de voix nous on premier tour on
est encore gagnant sur le par rapport
aux éditions précédentes
j'ai évoqué cette question de
l'abstention dans des communes de gauche
aussi l'abstention a été forte à trappes
c'est plus de 58% ou encore la verrière
56 % des communes de gauche donc votre
réaction
ces électeurs qui ne se déplace pas dans
vos évident dans vos villes oui alors
dans nos villes dans les villes en tout
cas qui sont globalement c'est vrai
qu'une association qui est plutôt forte
même si je pense qu'il faut quand même
noter et remarqué qu'il ya eu une
remobilisation extrêmement importante
sur le second tour vous parliez trappe
par exemple on a une hausse de 10% du de
la participation qui partait de très
loin
oui mais quand même une hausse de 10% ce
qui prouve que les électeurs ont su se
remobiliser au second tour après je
pense que ça pose cette abstention qui
est massif globalement une question
importante qui est la question la
différenciation entre la gauche et la
droite et je pense que ce refus d'aller
aux urnes ce refus de se saisir du
bulletin de vote c'est une manière pour
les électeurs de dénoncer
en tout cas de s'opposer à cette
indifférenciation droite gauche très
concrètement ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui ils ne ressentent pas
suffisamment dans les mesures qui sont
mises en place
la différence entre une politique de
gauche et une politique de droite ce qui
nécessite pour nous socialistes parti
parti de gauche 2-2 d'avoir une
inflexion sur la politique que nous
menons est d'être capable de parler de
manière plus plus juste de des questions
par exemple de service public dont on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps des
questions d'éducation aussi beaucoup a
été fait mais on peut encore faire et
progresser sur ces questions en tout cas
je pense qu'il ya voilà une une
infection à avoir qui doit être à mon
avis assez forte et assez rapide pour
pouvoir justement marqué cette
différence droite gauche et parti
socialiste
lorsque le parti socialiste se désiste
dans certaines régions ça peut être le
cas pour l'ile-de-france mais là aussi
ça brûle pas un petit peu les cartes
pour les électeurs je pense que dans
certaines régions le choix a été fait
effectivement parce que les socialistes
ont considéré qu'il y avait un risque
fort que le front national prennent des
régions et que ça fait partie des des
réflexes républicain que l'on a d'être
capable de se désister ce qui je voue la
corne être pas forcément la règle
qui est d'appliquer systématiquement du
côté du côté de la droite mais en tout
cas pour nous il à être toujours été
clair que nous devions nous opposer à la
victoire du front national et je pense
que de ce point de vue là on peut être
soulagé qu'aucune région de passe au
front national lors de ces élections
pour les républicains sur l'abstention
oui alors il ya quelque chose qui me
dérange dans ce discours ambiance et on
sous-entend que les électeurs seraient
manipulable d'une part d'autre part qui
ne saurait pas faire la différence que
nous élus nous saurions faire la
différence entre un programme de gauche
et un programme de droite ait eu que eux
n'y arriverait pas je pense qu'ils ont
très bien vu la différence d'ailleurs
valérie pécresse a gagné 100 120 mille
voix par rapport au premier tour dans
les yvelines
ils savent faire la différence entre un
parti qui n'a pas voulu débattre qui
n'avait pas de programme il ya une
absence de programme total qui avait fui
tous les débats et un parti qui
travaille depuis des années avec des
solutions concrètes des propositions
concrètes vous parler du bilan tout à
l'heure le très bon bilan
excusez moi ça me fait légèrement
sourire le bilan en termes de transport
allait demander aux usagers du rer à si
le bilan est bon allez demander en eau
de lycéens aux lycéens je prends encore
l'exemple de sa retrouver des valseuses
gallois où il pleut à l'intérieur des
qui dès qu'il fait mauvais enfin voilà
le bilan est catastrophique
les franciliens l'ont vu maintenant nous
avons une grande responsabilité je le
répète et nous l'assumerons au maximum
on va écouter de réaction de mr à
présent vous resterez agir si vous
voulez très brièvement
oui donc ce qu'il y avait de l'ump est
effectivement savalli de ce qu'on dit
depuis des années comment les électeurs
de droite peuvent s'y retrouver quand on
appelle à voter à droite comme les
électeurs de gauche peuvent s'y
retrouvent effectivement quand on
appelle à voter à droite au nord en paca
moi je pense jeu il faut rendre hommage
aux candidats de la gauche sur l'est qui
lui s'est maintenue et tout à fait il a
tout à fait raison c'est ça valide c'est
véritablement un choix démocratique
les gens peuvent s'exprimer tout ça
scandaleux qu'on puisse effectivement
joué avec les donner des consignes de
vote qui n'ont aucun sens on va écouter
de réaction de mr à présent je vous le
disais celle du maire de trappes
tout d'abord dans sa ville la liste de
claude bartolone à atteindre les 61 +2
61% mais on le disait l'abstention a été
forte même si elle est un petit peu
moins forte qu'au premier tour on écoute
le maire de trappes dit malade la
participation aux élections c'est un
geste citoyen qu'il faut faire
au maximum mais on a on a 10% de plus de
deux au temps et quand je regarde la
moyenne du taux d'infection ou d
authentification ce qui est une chose
dans l'eau sans fin on est toujours
entre 40 et 45 ici à trappes
si je regarde la ville avant de regarder
l'extérieur 1 d'abord une mobilisation
des habitants accusant 8 502 temps de
plus que lors du premier tour
et deuxièmement une réaffirmation des
fois républicain philosophiques et
politiques de la majorité de la
population puisqu'on est à 61 8 pour la
ligue 2 alice de bartolone qui
correspond à à l'union de la gauche et
est donc j'en suis satisfait pour la
ville de trappes et ça nous encourage à
continuer l'action politique que nous
menons pour la verrière à présent ville
communiste et 58% des électeurs se sont
prononcés pour claude bartolone le
report à gauche a bien fonctionné pierre
laurent du front de gauche vous êtes au
premier tour autour des 16 % à moins que
le niveau niveau mental voilà pour ces
deux réactions sur saint quentin en
yvelines on va se focaliser un petit peu
plus sur cette victoire de valérie
pécresse valérie pécresse qui fait
basculer l'ile-de-france à droite après
17 ans à gauche avec jean paul huchon
concrètement qu'est ce qui va changer
demain
mais déjà on va prendre les problèmes à
bras le corps ce qui n'a pas été fait
depuis 17 ans il
la gauche s'est complètement laisser
embourber dans voilà dans les habitudes
dans
une action est donc voilà veille
pécresse quand on la connaît un peu
c'est une femme d'action
c'est une femme de parole et une femme
d'action et donc c'est ça notre sécurité
à mettre tout à fait sa priorité ça va
être de réorienter le budget sécu et le
budget de la région sur la sécurité il
avait été divisé par cinq par la gauche
quand on connaît la situation actuelle
c'est assez aberrant
donc ça va être une sa priorité
également l'emploi bien sûr avec une
grande conférence sur l'emploi au mois
dès le mois de janvier avec tous les
acteurs pour mettre cela au devant des
priorités de la région comme ça devrait
être ça aurait dû être le cas pendant 18
ans sur les priorités les nouvelles
priorités de la région qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
oui bah moi je le disais je pense que
j'ai une inquiétude au vu des conditions
dans lesquelles valérie pécresse a été
élue une inquiétude quand je vois par
exemple les dispositifs qui ont été mis
en place par la gauche je pense par
exemple au pass contraception dans les
lycées
quid quand on voit enfin quid de
l'avenir de ce type de dispositif quand
on voit que valérie pécresse a été élu
avec le soutien d'organisations comme la
manif pour tous qui sont opposés à ce
type de d'engagement et de systèmes de
prévention en faveur des lycéens quel
avenir pour le chèque santé aussi qui
était une aide à destination des
étudiants boursiers pour qu'il puisse
accéder une complémentaire santé
quel avenir se passe navigo demi-tarif
faut rappeler que valérie pécresse était
vent debout s'est opposée puis a changé
d'avis à nouveau été contre le passage
du pass navigo à 50% pour tous ce qui
est un vrai une vraie mesure de pouvoir
d'achat notamment pour les habitants des
banlieues et pour les équipements en
particulier
donc quel avenir pour ce type de
dispositif et puis on parlait des
transports moi je j'ai une vraie
interrogation c'est à dire qu'on nous
parle d'investissements dans les
transports dont va rénover du jour au
lendemain quasiment toutes les rames de
transport alors qu'on sait très bien
quand on veut être sincère et honnête
que c'est des plans qui met du temps
avec mise en oeuvre que ça ne peut pas
être fait en claquant des doigts et que
la région s'était réellement investi et
qu'il ya une progression tout au long de
la mandature
quel voilà quelques gages on peut donner
à ce type d'engagement
quand on a à la tête de la région une
candidate qui revendiquait le triple des
mesures d'économies par rapport à ce qui
à défaut au niveau national c'est à dire
qu'au niveau national le gouvernement a
mis en place 50 milliards de réduction
des dépenses publiques valérie pécresse
ont demandé 120 ou 130
donc moi j'ai un peu de mal à croire
dans tous et ses promesses de campagne
quand derrière on demande de diminuer
drastiquement la dépense publique
comment va-t-elle financer ce dont elle
parle beaucoup de choses sur la question
de la santé de l'allée du transport et
une politique d'austérité est ce que ça
sera à l'ordre du jour devrait dire que
la première chose d'une preuve de
promesses qui peuvent être tenues c'est
de montrer comment on finance un
programme et valérie pécresse parmi tous
les candidats était la seule a expliqué
point par point ligne par ligne
comment elles finançaient chacune de ces
mesures alors que on n'a rien vu de
l'autre côté on n'a rien vu elle a
proposé 400 millions d'économies comme
en 2d pass navigo unique encore de la
mésinformation de la désinformation
comme tout au long cette campagne elle a
dit qu'elle ne le remettrait pas en
cause mais elle a voté contre dans les
débats quand ça a été mise en place
parce que on se pose encore une question
nous c'est comment on finance tout ça
enfin vous vous proposer des mesures
sans vous demander comment les financer
la sage et très bien les flancs tard il
vient d'avoir une mauvaise mesure que la
finition
donc voilà new health elle a eu le
mérite de se poser la question comment
elles financent donc elle s'est engagée
à le maintenir en de finances ans sans
augmentation d'impôts voilà donc c'est
la preuve que l est
sérieuse et que ce sont des mesures qui
peuvent être tenus françois simeoni vaut
y aller siéger dans l'opposition fin
vous n'allez pas siéger parce que vous
étiez cinquième sur la liste dans les
yvelines futur il y aura d'autres 3 et
louis villemer votre formation va siéger
vous serez dans l'opposition ce que tu
ne veux rien c'est vous conseil régional
puisqu'on était on y est on y est absent
depuis les élections on va être là on va
rentrer en france moi entrer à 22 donc
on va pouvoir en faire entendre notre
voix et quand on voit les effectivement
les 10 des votes des madame pécresse sur
la mandature précédente qui avait quand
même 70 % des décisions qui ont été
évoqués en commun avec les socialistes
qui valide complètement ce qu'on appelle
l'ump est maintenant au niveau des
crédits
voilà demain on rase gratis vous parlez
de sécurité avec avec qui on va faire
cette sécurité avec les les dix neuf
mille militaires gendarmes policiers qui
ont été supprimés une sous sarkozy je
pense que c'est cette sont des propos
qui sont complètement irréaliste demain
ça sera la suite on continuera avec les
mêmes on continuera à subventionner
notamment l'accueil des migrants ce qui
a été voté par madame par madame
pécresse
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas deux il y
aura pas de véritable changement d'un
véritable changement il va être de
l'autre côté on fait on est la seule
opposition crédible qui propose une
défense de l'état nation par rapport à
une europe
constitué de région est dirigée par des
technocrates et bruxelles ont fait une
pause au cours de ces discussions
en plateau pour repartir à présent pour
le quartier général hier soir de valérie
pécresse nous étions sur place une de
nos équipes y était fanny bourdillon et
puis juste après nous irons aussi au qg
de claude bartolone et de vallerand de
saint-just pour dallas pauvres ce
reportage fanny brody ont donc hier soir
la droite francilienne a fêté la fin de
17 ans de pouvoir socialiste les
militants ont pu savourer leur victoire
enfin j'ai envie de dire et ça fait
plaisir de voir que les franciliens font
confiance à valérie pécresse et
l'ensemble de son équipe et à son
programme et qu'ils ont ils ont été
convaincus par valérie pécresse mais
qu'ils ont également désavoué la gestion
socialiste
dix sept années passées pourtant le
score était très serré à 21h hier soir
la prudence était de mise dans ce café
parisien où journalistes et militants
attendaient les résultats du second tour
au qg des républicains les sourires
commencent à apparaître aux fenêtres
enfin peu avant 22 heures valérie
pécresse vient annoncer sa victoire cher
francilienne cher franchir
j'aime notre région mais je sais que
vous attendez désormais non pas des
déclarations d'amour mais les preuves
d'amour et bien dans les six prochaines
années nous allons tout donner pour
l'île de france et vive la fin la tête
de liste yvelines valérie pécresse
remporté 44 % des suffrages devant son
adversaire principal de ce second tour
le socialiste claude bartolone crédité
de 42% des voix
dans cette triangulaire le fn arrive
troisième avec 14 % les républicains
remportent donc la région avec une
avance très restreinte
bien sûr on extrêmement content que les
électeurs aient choisi vraiment de faire
le choix du changement c'était pas
évident sets serrés et donc ils ont
petit bourrellerie pécresse et je
prolongerai tous reconnaissants
maintenant faut être clair il pas de
triomphalisme on est bien sûr content
fêter cette victoire comme il se doit
mais va falloir ne pas décevoir derrière
pas le temps de se reposer
valérie pécresse deviendra
officiellement président de la région la
plus peuplée de france ce vendredi lors
du conseil d'installation avec un
objectif clair faire de l'île de france
la première région d'europe un objectif
qu'on doit à table tous ensemble sans
oublier les habitants d'île de france
sans oublier aucun de ces territoires
c'est l'enjeu qui est devant nous c'est
aussi le message que nous avons entendu
et je l'aiderai gelée de rêve tous les
parlementaires d'île de france et je
l'aiderai avec la sensibilité
particulière qui est la mienne pour le
territoire
en 2010 la candidate de l'union de la
droite et du centre avait perdu face à
jean paul huchon avec un écart de plus
de 10 points
hier soir elle tenait sa revanche ce que
vit
spectacle tout à l'heure lors de sa
conférence de presse je suis libre
exemple des camps des clans des parties
je crois que c'est ce que les français
attendent aujourd'hui une nouvelle façon
de faire la politique qui tient dans
l'action et l'intérêt général pour
certains le dérapage de bartolone à
trois jours du scrutin final où il avait
déclaré que sa rivale défend d encre
versailles neuilly et la race blanche
lui aurait coûté la victoire
la bêtise de la traité de versailles à
jouer on va aller se réunir à versailles
et après ça ben ben moi personnellement
j'ai été élu conseiller régional la
queue
évidemment on se remette au travail très
dur c'est une campagne très rude
vraiment je l'espère qu'on va en tirer
tous des leçons parce qu'il ya encore il
fallait des expressions comme été
utilisée surtout entre les deux tours
qui n'étaient pas dignes avec 121 sièges
au conseil régional d'aleri pécresse
remporte cette région phare de 12
millions d'habitants
elle devrait quitter son poste de député
des yvelines dans les prochaines
semaines les républicains qui vont donc
bénéficier de 121 des 209 sièges en
ile-de-france l'installation officielle
se fera vendredi matin modem et udf a
aussi siégé à ses côtés ses résultats et
sur ses résultats sur cette question du
rapprochement entre les républicains et
le centre écouter bruno milian c'est le
président du modem 78 lui aussi été
candidat dans les yvelines d'ailleurs
les scores nous oblige à la modestie de
toute façon est de toute façon pour moi
en tout cas pour le stress que je suis
une victoire quelle que soit la taille
de la victoire qu'elle soit éclatante ou
qu'elle soit c'est il n'y a pas matière
à avoir des éclats de joie et à se
répandre partout il ya surtout matière à
se mettre au boulot pour ne pas décevoir
ceux qui nous ont élus et pour faire
adhérer ceux qui nous ont pas si vous
venez nous rejoindre nous parlons
aujourd'hui des résultats sur le second
tour en ile de france avec une attention
particulière sur les yvelines concernant
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines à présent une nouvelle fois la
droite est en tête mais la gauche
résiste à guyancourt par exemple presque
52 % pour claude bartolone sur montigny
le bretonneux 47 % contre 43 % mais
l'écart en termes de voix n'est pas si
important entre les deux candidats
écouter le maire de montigny également
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin le
divers droite michel loger c'est au
micro de mickaël millero valérie
pécresse se confirme son résultat du
premier tour puisqu'elle était déjà en
tête et le reste au second tour et je
veux dire à la grande satisfaction c'est
que d'habitude aux élections générales
siroter que le maire de montigny n'est
pas en course c'est toujours la gauche
ce qui s'impose à montigny et bien là
c'est valérie pécresse qui s'impose à
monter ni pour ma plus grande
satisfaction
ce qui est aussi important est
encourageant c'est que quand je regarde
les résultats de 2010 je me souviens que
même que jean paul huchon
avait réalisé un score de 58 à 70 % à
montigny-le-bretonneux
donc on voit que en cinq ans il ya eu un
basculement important françois simeoni
pour le front national je voudrais juste
vous faire réagir sur la ville de
montigny le bretonneux puisqu'on vient
d'entendre le maire vous disais tout à
l'heure il ya eu ce vote on va dire
peut-être utile de vos électeurs qui ont
choisi de faire barrage à la gauche mais
sur montigny le bretonneux le fn passe
de 1600 voix mais 300 voix de 13 à 9 %
malgré tout pour peser même dans une
opposition il faut réussir à mobiliser
ses électeurs
c'était justement le même problématique
à montigny-le-bretonneux commerçants ils
ont encore une fois je vous lis des
électeurs du front national ont fait ce
choix ou deuxième tours de deux sorties
en à gauche parce que les bouchers et
nous les propos qui ont été tenus en
tournée avec instant où les importants
vous auriez plus dé lui ont valu à notre
cause et pierré manière plus importante
que bien évidemment mais il est clair
que il ya un choix qui est fait par les
électeurs on ne maîtrise pas le choix
des électeurs
ils ont la liberté de le considérer qu
effectivement il fallait sortir la
gauche une gauche qui traite les
versaillais je suis élu à versailles
télédéclaration je suis élu à versailles
traiter les versailles et comme ils ont
été traités c'est complètement
inadmissible de tenir des propos comme
ça on peut se demander même à quel point
ça n'a pas amené les versaillais à se
porter justement davantage aux urnes ce
dimanche je pense que ce soit eu un
effet on va coûter une nouvelle fois le
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines il nous parle de
l'ensemble des résultats sur cette
agglomération sur saint quentin en
yvelines dans quatre des sept communes
valérie pécresse est en tête aller
pécresse s'impose dans beaucoup de
villes
alors certes leur réalise aussi des
scores importants dans les villes tenues
par la gauche notamment ou à guyancourt
à la dernière et attrapes et je dire ce
sont des scores tout relatif qu'il faut
regarder puisque là aussi si je regarde
les résultats de 2010 les scores étaient
beaucoup plus importants puisque c'était
beaucoup plus de 70 pensent on était
presque à 80% des résultats pour jean
paul huchon
donc on voit bien que la l'électorat de
gauche s'effrite au niveau de
l'agglomération de saint quentin une
réaction à présent pour le parti
socialiste cette fois-ci puisqu'on parle
de saint quentin en yvelines
vous qui connaissez l'agglomération de
50 ans puisque vous siéger dans
l'opposition sur la ville d'elancourt
une réaction au global ce qui vient
d'être dit alors au global sur 2,5 sur
saint quentin en yvelines le résultat
est plutôt bon pour l'ensemble de la
gauche puisque la gauche arrive en tête
claude bartolone arrive en tête sur sur
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec 46% des
voix devant devant valérie pécresse sur
la 11e circonscription qui la
circonscription trappe elancourt la
verrière circonscription benoît hamon la
gauche l'a aussi arrive en tête donc des
résultats plutôt satisfaisants et pour
ce qui me concerne à elancourt bon on a
aussi eu un vrai travail de fond avec
des robes initiation 46%
oui avec quand même une la gauche qui
arrive en tête sur 11 euros sur 19 dont
plus de la moitié des bureaux de vote
donc des résultats qui sont plutôt
plutôt satisfaisant de ce point de vue
là sur un point de vue d'un point de vue
local et qui montre que le travail de
mobilisation doit être de se poursuivre
et permettent de à nos électeurs de se
mobiliser
c'est ce qu'on a entendu dimanche soir
sur les plateaux télé au niveau national
tout le monde a gagné en fait c'est un
petit peu ça comment vous analyser ça de
voir aussi que la gauche a résisté mais
écoutez nous en tout cas pour parler des
républicains dans les yvelines au gain
multiplie par deux notre nombre d'élus
donc c'est une vraie victoire de la
liste de valérie pécresse dans les
yvelines
au niveau national on passe d'une région
républicaine à cette région donc la vie
tellement c'est une victoire pour la
droite par rapport à la gauche qui qui
s'écroule et donc voilà donc ces il
suffit de regarder les chiffres pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
le département est maintenant à droite
l'agglomération la plupart des
agglomérations sont aussi à droite la
droite la gauche qui a aussi perdu de
nombreuses communes lors des dernières
municipales nous sommes allés rencontrer
le maire d'elancourt justement jean
michel fourgous lui est aussi le premier
adjoint chargé de l'économie à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 4 ont-ils
maintenant de valérie pécresse puisque
tous les voyants sont au vert pour la
droite
écoutez je pense que madame pécresse est
la plus une culture économique
elle sait elle sait attirer les talents
elle s'est attiré les capitaux elle elle
prend pas des mesures idéologiques
contre le monde de l'entreprise
donc elle est capable de créer un climat
de confiance de restaurer aussi un
climat avec l'europe parce que la région
ne profitait plus des aides européennes
parce que l'europe est ce soit libérale
nous on va pouvoir construire des
projets région département cas ce qui
bien sûr beaucoup plus fructueuse
parce qu'on avait beaucoup de mal à
travailler avec eux et je compte sur mon
âme pécresse elle l'a dit dans sa
campagne pour que vraiment rétablir la
justice l'équité entre les gens entre
les communes et puis surtout voilà
retrouver un niveau d'investissement
mais mme pécresse qui connaît le monde
économique connaît le monde de la r&d la
recherche et du développement
savoir sur quel secteur vous allez
investir c'est très important il faut
comprendre la recherche et je viens moi
je lui fais totale confiance en tout cas
et je suis très heureux de son arrivée
bien sûr et est de l'île de france ou
dans quelques instants nous irons au qg
de claude bartolone à paris on les
équipe de télé fils étaient également
présentes ont fait juste un petit détour
par magny les hameaux c'est une ville
qui est détenue par le parti socialiste
mais là-bas le score a été très serré 44
55 %
pour valérie pécresse contre 43,21 pour
claude bartolone
nous allons entendre tout de suite le
maire de la commune et la responsable de
son opposition aurore bergé qui connaît
bien valérie pécresse puisqu'elle a été
également dans son équipe de campagne
mais en 2010 au niveau de l'île de
france forcément force
jean logique après la liste que vous et
cheney avait claude bartolone et le
rassemblement à l'aube du gauche n'était
pas favori non plus sur sur l'ensemble
vu le contexte le politique nationale
une déception de ce côté et puis on sera
qui est que le rassemblement de gauche
de manière générale est un vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui et c'est ce travail là qu'il
faut réussir à faire nous devons
travailler toutes et tous sur sur le
lien social sur pour lutter contre
contre la peur de l'autre et et c'est
tout le travail qu'on a engagés à manier
labeaume et qui équipe à terminer et on
le voit bien les soubresauts réguliers
que nous pourrons voir au moment des
crises ça concerne ce le premier tour
valérie était arrivée en tête
c'est évidemment une grande satisfaction
c'est à dire que depuis que moi je suis
impliqué à manille maintenant ça fait
quelques années on travaille et on
travaille beaucoup et je pense que tout
simplement le travail paye je crois que
ce qui a fait la différence par rapport
à 2010 c'est que valérie pécresse était
totalement libre dans cette campagne et
qu'elle a fait sa campagne elle ne sait
rien laisser imposer qu'elle ne se
laisser imposer personne aucune
thématique de campagne elle a dit ce
qu'elle avait à dire
elle a fait la campagne comme elle
entendait la faire sur le terrain ou
plus près nous partons tout de suite
donc pour le qg de claude bartolone a
paris vous avez vécu la soirée
électorale du côté de valérie pécresse
voici comment cela s'est déroulé du côté
du parti socialiste et de ses alliés
europe écologie et front de gauche
attendent la fin
mais pour jouer à quelques milliers de
voix et pour l'instant on veut pas dire
qu'ils gagnent ce qu'on sait c'est que
le fn fait moins pour ce qui était prévu
et que ses atouts a tenté tension hier
soir au qg de claude bartolone le
candidat socialiste est dans un premier
temps annoncé perdant face à la
candidate de la droite valérie pécresse
elle a préparé les choses très très très
très tôt mais bon attendre attendre
on est dans l'état d'esprit qu'on attend
se dit qu'elle aimait jouer qu'il serait
encore des bureaux à dépouiller
donc on se dit à la fois pour l'instant
c'est mauvais mais il ya entre ces
d'espoir donc c'est un peu bizarre c'est
un peu mitigé un la liste union de la
droite menée par valérie pécresse
obtient 43 points 80 % des suffrages en
ile de france c'est seulement un point
et demi de plus que claude bartolone un
résultat serré après un premier tour
pour agent pour la gauche tous partis
compris avec 40% des suffrages
je remercie les uns et les autres
d'avoir su dépasser nos différences pour
parvenir à l'unité
une nouvelle majorité va s'installer au
conseil régional d'ile-de-france en
républicain je lui souhaite bonne chance
car il s'agit avant tout de la réussite
de tous les franciliens ont su ce qui
est la clé du second tour en ile de
france c'est qu'il ya des électeurs du
front national qui ont voté valérie
pécresse là où
manifestement c'est pas forcément le cas
ailleurs en tout cas en ile de france il
ya eu des transferts de voix du front
national vers la librairie pécresse pour
raison notamment d'une campagne qui a
été une campagne qui à côté de valérie
pécresse fait des électeurs du front
national
la principale cible autres cas de ces de
ses différentes déclarations les a
séduits ça a marché
suffisamment pour la mettre devant nous
dans les yvelines la différence entre
les deux premières listes est bien plus
significative avec six points d'écart au
bénéfice de valérie pécresse
claude bartolone obtient lui 34 % des
voix à l'échelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet attrape
que le candidat socialiste obtient son
meilleur score avec 61% des suffrages ce
qui est sûr c'est que dans les quartiers
populaires il ya eu un sursaut de
mobilisation moi je vois sur la ville
envahi de trappes
on est à plus de 60% pour la gauche donc
il ya une mobilisation mais avec une
participation qui restent encore
largement insuffisantes on va sur le 93
aussi un ou même s'il ya une majorité
pour la gauche en nombre de voix c'est
c'est difficile pour ce second tour
claude bartolone avait fusionné ses
listes avec celles des écologistes et du
front de gauche
je prends acte des résultats je félicite
aleri pécresse et ses colistiers
c'est le sait la règle démocratique les
élections d'un gagnant perdu en ce qui
nous concerne nous aurons un groupe au
sein du conseil régional et on
continuera à défendre un projet
écologiste pour la région et on sera
attentif à tous les dossiers la
dynamique pour la gauche au deuxième
tour elle était évidente sinon nous
n'aurions pas fait un tel score au
deuxième tour aux mairies pécresse
remporte la région de 1 point seulement
et on peut s'interroger sur les raisons
de
du score qui est le sien au deuxième
tour aujourd'hui quand on voit
l'affaiblissement du front national si
nous avons bénéficié d'un très bon
report des écologistes et du front de
gauche sur la candidature de claude
bartolone
le front national a porté ses voix en
partie sur valérie pécresse à l'issue de
ce second tour l'union de la gauche
obtient 66 sièges sur les 209 que compte
le conseil régional d'île de france
ce que je voudrais savoir c'est parce
qu'on parlait de l'union de la gauche
notamment avec ce reportage et puis on
l'a vu avec les l'alliance qui s'est
fait autour de la gauche et du parti
socialiste demande comment vous aller
siéger
il y aura un seul et unique groupe une
seule voie pour la gauche sera d'accord
tout le monde sera d'accord pas
forcément ça a toujours été le cas c'est
à dire qu'à des sensibilités qui
s'expriment et que même quand on a un
groupe constitué les choix de vote qui
sont faits c'est toujours le résultat de
la répercussion ecologie le front de
gobi mais comme ça a déjà été le cas
dans d'autres dans d'autres
circonstances dans d'autres lieux où on
a d un moment l'envi de mener un combat
en commun et je pense qu'il y aura
effectivement la nécessité que
l'ensemble des partis et des différentes
tendances de gauche qui vont siéger
ensemble au conseil régional
qu'elle soit dans une logique de
construction et d'ô position commune
je pense que ce sera indispensable si on
veut pouvoir justement porter la voix
des franciliens qui qui nous ont fait
confiance pour les défendre à la région
dans contexte d'autant plus les
inquiétant auquel a été élu valérie
pécresse
pour terminer cette édition du 7 8
politique qu'on s'attarde à présent sur
la question du front national va le
rendre saint-just qui était votre
candidat trésorier du front national
avocats de la formation politique
également réalisé le plus mauvais score
au niveau national comment vous
l'expliquez la région ile de france est
traditionnellement une région qui est
qui n'est pas effectivement excellente
pour nous en terme de deux voix je pense
que les sondages au moment où le premier
tour et tourner normalement autour de
25% qui n'a jamais atteint oui oui mais
bon les sondages vous savez souvent on
peut supposer qu'ils sont ne surestime
un petit peu pour après dire voilà le
front national n'a pas réussi son
challenge je pense que c'est les 25 %
n'ont jamais été atteints
en ile de france alors pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui nous est comme travail à
faire pour convaincre je pense qu'il
faut effectivement puisque comme j'ai
dit le débat sur les idées au niveau
c'est insécurité immigration tout ça on
l'a gagné et déjà ce qu'il faut faire
l'effort qui est fait au niveau du front
national c'est convaincre sur la
validité notre programme économique sur
la pertinence de ce programme convaincre
sur l'aptitude du front national a
dirigé les exécutifs ce qui est ce qui
est très révélateur dans les mairies du
front national où on voit
qu'effectivement les scores ne font
qu'augmenter
donc les gens valides un exécutif dirigé
par le front national mais voilà il ya
un message à faire passer et notamment
dans l'électorat de droite je pense que
électorale comme versailles et saint
germain il faut travailler pour leur
faire comprendre effectivement que le
chemin suivi par la droite pourrait les
amener à des ponctions sur les comptes
bancaires parce que ils seront peut-être
pas au courant mais des directives
européennes ont échoué ont été prises en
décembre 2013 autorisant le prélèvement
sur les comptes bancaires et ça a été
validé dans le les lois nationales
depuis le 20 août de cette année notre
candidat va le rendre saint-just on va
l'écouter tout de suite puisqu'il était
forcément à son qg
son quartier général est hier soir et
les équipes de téléphiles et de radio
sensations avec qui nous avons réalisé
ce reportage
également il n'y a pas eu de
retournement de situation en faveur du
front national au second tour des
régionales en île de france
le candidat du fn valoran de saint-just
troisième du premier tour avec 18 points
41% a terminé également sur la dernière
marche du podium ce dimanche la liste du
frontiste a obtenu 14 0 2% des suffrages
très loin des 40 3 80% de la candidate
des républicains valérie pécresse et des
42,18 % de la liste socialiste conduite
par claude bartolone
c'est une déception ça n'est pas un
revers politique parce qu'encore une
fois je crois que notre nombre de voix
est extrêmement important nous sommes je
dédie le seul parti à ne pas nous être
déshonoré nous avons fait cela nous
arrivons à ce chiffre dans l'honneur de
façon unie et dans l'honneur
le front national a surtout perdu 4
points entre les deux tours dans la
région ile de france dans les yvelines
le fn est passé de 19 0 5% des suffrages
à 14 10 % attrape le parti frontiste qui
avait créé la sensation en sortant
deuxième des suffrages au premier tour a
reculé à la troisième position derrière
la candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse
le fn reste tout de même en tête dans
quatre communes des yvelines
je peux pas dire soit satisfaisant mais
c'est un soulagement c'est un
soulagement parce que souvenez vous au
départemental
on avait des candidats qui se trouvait à
peu près dans la même situation au 2ème
tour fait 20% au premier et qui se
retrouvaient à dix au deuxième
donc n'avoir que quatre points de moins
par rapport au premier tour
c'est satisfaisant enfin ses choix c'est
un soulagement
malgré cette baisse le front national a
réussi à obtenir 22 sièges sur les 209
que compte la région en 2010 le parti
n'avait aucun représentant en ile de
france
de toute façon mon but depuis le départ
recréer un groupe significatif au
conseil régional d'ile-de-france est
évidemment atteint et personne ne pourra
me contester cette réussite
comparativement à ce qui existait
auparavant puisque nous l'avions 0 élu
après les élections place au travail le
front national devrait s'attaquer dès
les prochaines séances aux grandes
thématiques économiques
on espère pouvoir favoriser des projets
qui est qui et qui sont favorables à à
tous les franciliens avec une gestion
saine des finances
personnellement avec mon expérience
financière j'espère pouvoir apporter une
analyse pertinente au niveau financier
du budget et des choix de dépenses et
on espère que l'argent du public et de
l'action régionale sera bien au service
des franciliens
moi ce que je critique c'est le fait
qu'il n'y ait que 350 millions d'euros
sur 5 milliards de budget pour l'action
économique
je peux critiquer certaines actions en
proposer d'autres et c'est extra mais à
l'aide de ce qui existe déjà avec des
novations avec des propositions
il faudra que nous nous nous y fassions
connaître et que nous allions voir tout
une bonne partie des entrepreneurs
d'ile-de-france pour la gauche et pour
monsieur huchon
ça n'était pas une action prioritaire il
ne faisait pas connaître et il n'a
travaillait pas à nous force
d'opposition à le faire les 22
conseillers régionaux du front national
prendront place lors de la première
séance du conseil régional programmé à
paris dans le 7e arrondissement
le vendredi 18 décembre cette édition
spéciale qui touche à sa fin prochain un
scrutin ce sera en 2010 cette gauche
comme droite vous avez appelé à faire
barrage en tout cas au fonds national
est appelé à un sursaut républicain
c'est comme ça qu'il a été qualifié vous
leur dites pas aux électeurs du front
national
aujourd'hui ce soir mais écoutez nous on
s'adresse à tout le monde et c'est ce
qui va faire la caractéristique de
valérie pécresse sait qu'elle va
s'adresser à tous les franciliens
nous n'opposons pas trappe à versailles
saint denis à vincennes nous parlons à
tout le monde
et voilà on se base sur l' un projet
nous allons construire un projet et il
sera valable
il sera proposé à tous les franciliens
pour la gauche aujourd'hui aux électeurs
qui sont abstentionnistes en tout cas du
front national vous vous mordez quoi
mais je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
sur les jeux les dix je pense qu'à une
véritable réflexion qu'on doit avoir sur
la politique qui est menée et comment on
arrive à s'adresser plus directement et
de manière plus plus percutante en
matière de mesures sur les services
publics sur l'action sociale sur sur les
salaires je pense que là il ya un vrai
enjeu une vraie question qui se pose et
puis deuxièmement
lady aussi sur la question du front
national la position pour nous et ferme
c'est à dire que nous refusons de courir
après les thèses et les thématiques du
front national entendre les inquiétudes
les questions posées par les électeurs
c'est une chose récupérer reprendre à
son compte les réponses qui sont
formulées par l'extrême droite pour nous
ce sera toujours non france a signalé
oui bah écoutez je ris parce que
effectivement j'ai de temps de temps
d'un système ump est ce qu'on dénonce on
en est seul jusqu'à une époque on
critiquait d'être seul on est seul face
à des coalition contre nature et seuls
ont réussi des scores jamais vu un du 45
en paca donc quand on est à 45,55 je
pense qu'on est très près du 49 51 et en
2017 on a très bon espoir et je demande
à tous les électeurs de manière générale
tous les français de se motiver et de
comprendre la pertinence de notre
programme
merci à tous les trois d'être venu
commenter ces différents résultats au
niveau de l'île de france et du
département des yvelines on les revoit
une dernière fois ses différents
résultats pour notre région
puis pour le head département prochain
7,8 politique mardi prochain à 18h30 en
direct et d'ici là nous reviendrons dans
le journal de vendredi sur la séance
d'installation du conseil régional
excellente soirée sur tv films